this was a talk I gave actually at
University of Michigan about three
months ago then I retired in the
meantime but I thought well this is the
uh this is a good to go
um here I have to mention if you want to
contact me and check the papers that's
my Ford address if you want to contact
me this is my my now active address
I have a bunch of people to recognize
there but I I was told this is going to
be shorter presentation so I'm gonna go
fast through this I apologize fairly
technical again I apologize send me an
email if you have questions okay here is
a question you saw the title of the talk
right why why would anyone want the
feedback loop to be unstable in my long
career no one ever asked me to make a
feedback loop unstable however there are
examples right of unstable feedback loop
biology and economics of course a lot
fewer in engineering but flip-flop is
unstable system nuclear Chain Reaction
unstable
here in multi-agent systems it turns out
that there is a relationship between
fluidity of motion right liveness and
and stability of the loops created by
the by the agents and this is this this
is what we found
let's remove this in your way
gridlock possible stable interagent
Loops gridlock avoided unstable
faster instability more graceful passing
so we want instability in fact we want
fast instability if we can act so how do
we how do we get to this okay
there is a lot of work to get to that so
first I want to talk about computational
complexity
so can we uh have these multi-agent
systems uh as a convex optimization
problem there is a big difference you'll
see in a moment uh then I'm going to
introduce control barrier functions
illustrate this on a vehicle experiment
uh
I'm gonna go talk about multi-agent
system and colonomic robots uh review
some cbf-based algorithms show Monte
Carlo simulations and then the key part
of the talk is towards the end when I'm
explaining the results with the
stability analysis negotiations is
actually this stability versus
instability
and illustrate this with more complex
examples than the analysis is done for
so I
think a lot of into one slide here
apologies
why cbfs my shortest answer I can
provide is because I get the convex
correct program
uh as Rockefeller said the great
Watershed optimization is between
linearity nonlinearity but convexity and
non-convexity
if I have a cop program I have favorable
scaling with the number of Agents
number of AIDS it's linear if I have
decentralized so if I only take care of
myself and ignore everyone else
assume they are going to keep doing
whatever they are doing they are not
agents right then it scales it linearly
with number of Agents if I have a
centralized system or co-optimization
theoretically number of agents to the
power four
but actually we observed number of Ages
scaled for number between 4 and 32. this
is interesting because 32 agents 4 and
32 were done with human in the loop
experiment so I can run 32 agents in
real time because humans obviously
require real-time computation on
approximation
I don't think you can do it with
anything
that looks like this so Alternatives you
can see everything is NP hard all the
other options NP hard meaning
essentially really difficult discrete
search is officially exponential but
whenever it says MP you can you can say
it's pretty much exponential
now I can't talk
too much about this there is a lot of
these are just review articles that I'm
listing there so if you want to review
the last one has I think 120 pages so
you can read a lot about this but
obviously I I have to go on a tangent
actually
so the tangent here is control barrier
functions
I have System Dynamics could be
non-linear it's important that we it be
linear in in the control input
we have admissible set so here I have I
say well I want to keep my let's say
vehicle or robot above the water line
right I don't want the water the my
robot to go down which is very
appropriate given the situation in the
California
um so you don't want uh the robot to be
submerged so you have to keep it for a
the rate is greater than zero uh and
this age is the control barrier function
if I can find U such that H dot plus
Lambda H is greater than zero think
about what it means for a moment I have
an obstacle here I'm moving towards it
let's say the distance is H it's
decreasing
the rate of decrease should be
proportional to the distance but not
faster than that if you can control the
constant Lambda then then you pick that
Lambda whatever is appropriate
in any case
there are two Alternatives here the
other one is kind of if you don't have a
constraint on you
uh basically if you lose control
over over age dot you wonder what is
right what is what remains to be
positive
relative reason 2007. so basically if I
have an H
I can find you such that this is
satisfied or in other words that this is
just a a train trained rule formula
right that that is satisfied greater
than zero if I can satisfy that and then
h of T is greater than h of 0 e to the
minus Lambda t
so I guarantee if I start with positive
H it stays positive right
pretty good
important thing is the constraint is
affine in control
so when I set up this this way as a
quadratic program so someone comes in
this is a cbf-based safety filter
so if you give me a control u0 that does
whatever performance you want right it
goes to the destination for example
and there is a constraint let's say
there is a water there it says stay out
of the water that's the second one you
say okay I can I can do this
uh
I need to solve this I I want control I
just closes the original which satisfy
the given constraint this is a quadratic
program it's a convex it's nice it's
easy to solve
um
the important thing is no additional
tuning parameters I really have nothing
to do but this is it
so
if I do the CBF I have some
guarantees
QP problem is feasible the resulting
control is lips is continues which is
which is important you'll see in a
moment how with the importance of
continuity
I guarantee obviously X stays greater
than zero local stabilization property
and it's a mild technical assumptions
are inherited from u0 so if your car
come close to where you want to be to
your destination then then use zero
dictates what happens there
um now
let's talk about robustness
so I have this uh
I'm allowing
you you saw that I'm allowing h of T to
go down to zero meaning I'm allowing
this to approach the boundary of C
well what if I have disturbances or
uncertainty or something right
uh
what what can I do well I can actually
move this a little bit make this h of x
a little bit smaller right basically
shifts it down and shifts it a little
bit away what happens if I do this what
happens is once I cross this new
boundary there is a restoring Force
pushing me back out so if I have small
disturbance I need small
ETA if you want to to have this region
small if I need larger servants I need
to move it farther away basically what
happens is I have a trade-off I'm I'm
getting the the
the robustness but my obstacles got
bigger if I make them really big
well maybe I will not be able to to move
around right if my every obstacle is
huge then then there is no pattern but
there is a trade out there a little bit
finer uh let's say a little bit more
uh precise handling of this is if I put
a disturbance there and I have some
model and the disturbance looks like
that right that it enters there has a w
I know some limit on the disturbance
so
I can define a robust control barrier
functions basically it's the same thing
as before except I have put my worst
case disturbance there so it says even
in the worst case disturbance I can use
control U to
to
guarantee that H dot plus Lambda H is
greater than zero greater or equal to
zero
if I
and this is actually the definition
actually comes from my paper uh in
contrast to most of the other stuff
right so combining
these rcbf with the Baseline control I
can do two things I can use worst case
disturbance or maybe somehow I know the
disturbance all right partial you know
this term in this case I assume I pretty
much know these servants I can plug it
in right so I just satisfy first or
second
and uh and so this is the robust control
barrier function the second one is going
to play a role subsequently
there are new obstacles into barriers
well
and now how would you do that right uh
you saw that that that uh drawings for
the barrier functions it was obviously
non-convex but it doesn't matter for for
the barrier functions I have a
I treat them the same the Arizona one
tuning parameters it's easy to generate
barrier functions let me show you this
you have a Roomba robot you say I don't
want rumor to hit the wall
well there is a line there the equation
of line X plus b y plus C equals zero my
barrier function for the wall is just
that
right that's it
if I have a leg of the table and I know
the radius I can say okay keep that HD
greater than zero if I want to have some
stay a little bit more away I can make
it a little bit bigger use a barrier
margin right say okay make this make
this radius just a little bit bigger so
you're gonna stay
another two inches away from either the
wall or there if I have and in most
cases it will be the case
uh high order system it's not the
problem we handle it with a higher order
barrier constraint there is again a
little bit of technicality with the uh
now the
uh
the feasible set C now including H Dot
but that that's that depends on what
Lambda you you use but then anyway this
is this this can be done too
in any case you can see it's not too
difficult it's fairly straightforward
you see I have there is a wall there is
a desk there is something else there's
another Roomba robot no problem okay so
we have done all this
and we have done all this in uh
experiments right pretty much so these
chairs that you see there are actually
just circles they have this vehicle
stays away from the chairs right
first step is u0 there is a pad planning
start point target the waypoints pure
Pursuit
very straightforward right then someone
comes and put chairs there
uh
well the control steering and braking so
you can see how that sorry how that
works
um
this is all real time not sped up or
slowed down
I was this was copy time I was actually
in the uh in Michigan
virtually present in the vehicle when
they were doing the tests so they were
moving the chairs and sometimes it go
around the boat chairs on the same way
sometimes or in between that you you saw
that
looks more impressive from the inside
because the steering wheel turns quite
quickly
uh because you need to turn a bit low
speeds you need to turn a wheel a lot to
get uh this much Theory
uh in any case it works
now to the
kind of starting the second half of the
presentation
how about these Shares are not chairs
but there are other agents they have
their own idea what should happen right
how about traffic you can see here right
it's traffic in Paris
um well
tell me can you predict what others are
going to do two three seconds in the
future
probably not unless they are stationary
then the motorcycles come and that that
gets so you can see that right
anyway this this motivates our okay no
precedence right no rules right it's not
like all these guys coming from the
right they always have right away it's
yeah
yeah maybe but not not entirely
sometimes we humans do uh produce
gridlock you can see one here
uh so we are not perfect
avoiding interacting obstacles a lot of
work done on this
there is uh optimal reciprocal collision
avoidance work with the velocity cones
one interesting thing to know there it's
2011 paper it splits responsibility
between the two parties to avoid and
there is no third party in that in that
calculation so the third party
constraints are absent we call this
decentralized reciprocal it's reciprocal
because you have you take half of
responsibility don't take other part
counterparts uh
you know obstacles into account
another interesting thing is frozen
robot problem
you can see here uh uncertainty cones of
the people walking and if that robot up
in the corner if you ask the robot to
actually move in between them it's
probably not possible there is no way
you you can find it so you you basically
say okay I have to start moving to
create path for myself and this is done
by
optimizing for everyone and we refer to
this as co-optimization so you optimize
for yourself as well as others at the
same time
the the last set of papers is control
barrier functions and they can consider
uh centralized decentralized follower
decentralized reciprocal
these are our names this gets
centralized is theirs but but we call
these algorithms the centralized
follower and the center of the
reciprocal to make it clear what we are
doing in the subsequent presentation
so here back to Roomba robots and we
have these these multi-ravel problems
they're all agents they all have a
simple uh Dynamic second order right
positions velocities accelerations
distance based CBF I already said what
I'm what I would I would do this is just
the distance I had a little bit of a
radius margin doesn't play a big big
role in this presentation but it does
it's in the paper for for other reasons
so if you compute the second order uh
derivatives you get something on the
form a i JS plus b i j u i minus u j and
you want to keep that greater or equal
to zero that's a barrier constraint
um so each each one of of these
generates up each two ages generates a
pair of constraints which means it's
scale about number of Agents squared you
can see the formula there right if I
have 10 ages
I think 45. constraints grows quite fast
uh decentralized multi-agent controllers
um I'm doing okay I think
uh no common communication protocol each
agent computes its own best action
local optimization no planning for other
agents so here I have
you know what
sorry the centralized follower simply
says okay I'm responsive for awaiting
collisions there are no guarantee of
collision avoidance because they are too
optimistic on the passing side
once aij goes positive
they they think they can take the full
uh kind of a
slack to zero but if both decide to do
that then they call out you can see that
here
the centralized reciprocal is nicer
actually as long as the QP and you can
see QP actually there number of Agents
there so and it could be 10 agents as
long as it's feasible for everyone they
are going to avoid Collision however it
may be infeasible and you can see an
example here that one from the left one
from the right are moving the one in the
center wants to be stationary
but the both moving ones assume
dictionary is going to move because it
takes half of the responsibility right
but it can't
there is no accounting for third party
constraints in this you can see that
right I optimized I optimize only my own
uh
constraints with other ones and ignore
their problems right so here it becomes
infeasible they crash
centralized this is this is a good one
right
it requires communication
the central node Computing everything
knows everything computes for everyone
the guarantee
collision avoidance in particular
because we can guarantee feasibility
and this is one feasible action
so a proportional braking for everyone
is a feasible action
it's true even if these robots are
non-holonomic the same thing applies
feasible action is proportional breaking
if you have a limit on acceleration then
you have to limit the speed relative to
your your Lambda K Lambda K U Pick
k equal one or two one either one would
work but
you have two eigenvalues these are these
are minus Lambda one and the minus lamb
two are eigenvalues of that second order
iteration I mean
uh characteristic values of the second
order equation
so call optimization
Tesla uh
two years ago in AI they said well you
need to plan for ourselves and everyone
else jointly
we call it co-optimization but basically
optimize for everyone you have to be
aware if other ones have constraints
but this gets uh complex pretty quickly
right and I think they use discrete
search and I think they also use some
kind of neural network to kind of get
this into the feasible
the pick most likely scenarios and then
only cellulose that's what I think but
based on what they said in any case
here in my case I just have a complete
control set strategy
it's it has everyone's uh constraint
available however it doesn't have other
agents desired accelerations because it
doesn't know what U zeros are for other
ones doesn't know where they are going
right so
so basically uh
basically this is the uh the the two
actually makes makes it uh guarantee
collision avoidance for two agents
for more than two it does not but we
kept two because at least if if the
problem is only between the two this
guarantees that they are not going to
collide otherwise they're going to
collide even with two agents this is a
structure of the of the algorithm it
takes position velocities computes both
uses its own throws out the other one
discards the other one
and this I bring up because there is
another algorithm
which says
I compute this for both the same thing
except for W's what you saw before there
is no two we don't need to for this
predictor corrector for collision
avoidance or pcca
this is again our paper 21.
this is a structure now so so we use the
robust control barrier function you can
see two W's so there are uncertainties
right I say okay there is a disturbance
do I know this how do I know the
servants well I could take what I
computed
I'm sorry sorry
I can look at what I computed
uh compare it to the to what I measure
the other one do
say the difference is that the
uncertainty
feed it back I need a unit delay or
filter to break the algebraic Loop
otherwise I held your break Loop so I
can guarantee certain things for this
again feasibility I get a control I
control everyone in my in my world in
the ego vehicle world I control everyone
not in reality but visibility doesn't
repent depend on reality it depends what
time
giving myself as the degrees of freedom
wrs are bounded if these differences are
bounded so as long as they distance and
the relative velocities are bounded W's
are going to stay bounded
I have an interesting regardless of
their both implement pcca or only one
implements PC the other is
non-interacting I can prove that the age
of these states greater than
of delta T means something that goes to
zero delta T So the faster I sample the
smaller this thing gets so basically
delta T think of it in the delay I get
the information in
the shorter delay
the the better of eye but this is
obvious right if I have a delay in
getting information from the other I'm
going to potentially Collide because
it's always late to where the other
agent is
so but this tells me that if I sample
fast I only need a Epsilon radius margin
so here is what we compare that you're
going to see Monte Carlo simulations
here I have centralized
the centralized follower reciprocal
complete control set PCC every sample
data and pcca with low pass filter this
one I think that you that on the right
by the way
initially this Final Destination random
non-overlapping so you just pick them
around say okay you go to the to
wherever it is except for centralized
the other ones use only observed
quantities there is no exchange of
information this one I think is the
worst case for one of the pcca you can
see how how this goes right
this is one that took the longest
because they are facing one another I
think directly on at one point
they result
these are the results too much but
I'm I'm just gonna show you these two
things this is important first of all
let me show you that indeed
the violation is small for the
centralized pcca and two pccas and
indeed if you increase the sampling we
should show all of these disappear
uh
and then let me also show that that
number of gridlocks don't coincide with
the co-optimization versus decentralized
co-optimization does not solve the
problem of of gridlocks
you can also see here here is the the
max time
and you can see the three on the bottom
they're almost agreed are centralized
and two pcca there's very little
difference and very little difference
from run to run so you can see there is
while the other ones obviously have a
large variation
to combat the the
barrier uh violations you can make them
bigger obviously plays no role with the
with the three three uh good ones but
for the the centralizing CCS they kind
of grow bigger but they also slow them
down significantly an increased number
of gridlocks
deadlock resolution
uh
so
you have this uh you know people looked
at this right in particular the CBF
based on there some some things
they they usually consist of two steps
one is identify deadlock situation
and then once in 35 you execute the
prescribed maneuver uh it's well
choreographed if you run this video from
the paper you'll see how well I mean
they move they stop they rotate and they
move out
what is interesting Central's algorithm
was known to never gridlock but I don't
think anyone ever offered an explanation
why not
so let me try to do that
here
you have two cases dfdr and pcca
dfdr is known to gridlock occasional
this is almost completely symmetric
there's just a little bit off and you
can see they are not gonna unlock and
even if I put noise nothing happens they
still stay like this
it's a stable configuration in the in
this case pcca
it's not stable
okay but
oh
this is very complex right 24 states on
the right I can't analyze that I can't
even write a 24 by 24 Matrix on the on a
piece of paper so what I'm gonna do I'm
going to simplify this
now if you want something happen you
have to take out the degree of freedom
so this is one degree of Freedom
intersection they decide the passing
order which one goes first through this
intersection they are very simple X1
0x20 initial conditions they are
negatively obvious they start from
negative numbers V one zero V to zero
are their desired speed they want to
move
other desire V1 V2 our controls I have
standard CBF
uh and this one can think of this the
same problem as negotiating a
negotiating the passing in a merge right
who is going to go first through a merge
scenario and adding second order doesn't
change anything that's another uh kind
of fixed mode
so
decentralized reciprocal
it's given here
I'm just going to give you equations for
this decentralized reciprocal because I
I can write them down easily right so
it's here this is this is the solution I
keep different Lambda on Lambda 2.
to make a point that making one more
aggressive than the other doesn't solve
anything Lambda 1 Lam 2 is
aggressiveness right when you are going
to start braking are we gonna wait to
break late or break early here making
those two different buys you pretty much
I mean once less the more aggressive one
is go more likely to go first
but other than that does not solve the
gridlock problem
out of these equations I immediately get
that h of T always stays greater than
zero which is good I guarantee collision
avoidance
I can compute the eigenvalues
I'm going to skip the equilibrium set is
this Arc
right you can see the arc that's all all
this point when H equal to zero you can
see H equals zero is equilibrium here
and here
um
the eigenberries are zero and minus
Lambda 1 plus Lambda two and you can
from zero you can't really conclude this
in all in your systems you cannot
conclude much however
you'll notice that this is a because uh
well take a look
here for example you are here and if you
can see micros so you are there
X1 X2 are negative this is a positive
number if H is not zero this is positive
number on on this side so that gray
region
in that great region they don't go
backwards once they get close to H equal
to zero they are stuck right there
that's why it's stable
um
and it doesn't matter if lambda-112 are
very different or the same
it's all the same so just to show you
some simulations they would uh gridlock
for offsets less than Point too far with
these settings
here they pass barely you can see they
pass but they don't go backwards so if
this blue was just a little bit ahead it
wouldn't pass we ran the sweep in two
parameters you can see the results of
the sweep
UH 60 000 points about 15 gridlock
in this space of v0 and X2
centralized npcca centralized this is
the structure
I I know positions I compute for
everyone I Implement whatever I compute
this one gives you a single equilibrium
point
there
and it's unstable
so it's it's positive this this thing is
positive it means this equilibrium is
unstable the only way you get gridlock
is if you hit that line measure zero set
that goes straight into the into the uh
that goes straight into the equilibrium
point basically that's why people think
they never gridlock
pcca a little bit more complex more more
eigenvalues now has these these filters
but there is an unstable positive number
the same thing
and uh
an interesting thing zero I can make the
move from physical to controller space
so the first two are physical and the
second two are controller values
um interesting observations the faster
they go one they devices they want to go
the more unstable
the equilibrium is not not the faster
they go the faster they want to go even
if you start very close to age they're
going to move slowly but instability
does not depend on how close to HDI
depends on on
how fast they want to go
and uh
as they're always independent of design
parameters you can see that I mean there
is nothing I can I can do with design
parameters or there Lambda and tile
which are my design parameters have no
impact
at all on the instability
so pcca simulation
this this looks this is the same thing
as before much nicer obviously faster
you can see here well you have to hit
that
you have to hit the
stable manifold right on there is only
one point
that that gridlocks
now this is this is one that wasn't in
the paper
but it's often used I can feed back what
I observe
in the the other one does and this is
kind of a
in the game theoretic would be uh U
minus one or a minus I or a minus I
meaning what others are doing not what
I'm doing so I optimize only for myself
but I take into account what they are
doing and this has to come with because
of the static loop again it has to come
with some filtering or delay
uh
this thing is unstable
but there is a pair of unstable
eigenvalues
right this is Jordan form this is the
instability but it's slow instability
uh to to look at this uh take a look at
this one they pass
a little bit faster than uh then this
then this one this one but notice one
one thing the red one was closer
to the and it's going to go second first
thing second out
that's not a good feature right
but we observed it here and uh and this
thing obviously it's much slower and
they they would they would keep if you
let it run longer this thing would go
into the stable manifold
to Summer summarize I'm just comparing
these uh what was observed on the right
hand side observed gridlocks in five
agents cases and this 1D instability
analysis right and you can see Zero
gridlock if it's a if you say unstable
if you say stable there are gridlocks
observed so there is kind of this theory
of explains why we have this another
thing to observe
we don't know how to create these
unstable algorithms I don't I did not
know ahead of time that DF with v hat
will be unstable
we did not run stimulation first
I did the analysis first I said oh this
is unstable right let's run this the
simulation see if it indeed I get zero
and indeed with it however you can see
here you can see here this first and
second now has has consequences well uh
this is what I just had zero zero
gridlocks but take a look what they do
they are really reactive too reactive
I think
this this looks pretty ugly I think they
they are just trying to move out of the
way of the other ones which is not good
I think for the speed of response
and again I have some comments there but
anyway this is uh
details in all of this
but in any case the theory predicted
zero
uh
gridlocks we observe zero gridlocks
aside from the
reactivity which is not related okay
some multi-agent stable mode are
undesirable so it's I'm not saying oh
just make it unstable and things are
good no
number one non-confidence of today's
optimization methods produce
discontinuous results and you people
observe reciprocal dance in multi-aging
systems
uh it's difficult to adjust to other
agents intent if the other agent keeps
flip-flopping right if I say oh I'm
gonna go to the left I'm gonna go to the
right I don't know how to adjust to this
so here is simulation with the dynamic
window
which is well-known algorithm discrete
search well they crash humans do this
too
take a look left right left they are
going to crash
well the question is breaking was
available all along and they didn't do
it it was never optimal
it was good thing to do but
for these algorithms human as well as
the dynamic window it was never optimal
it was always sub-optimal and you use
optimal assuming the other one is going
to do
what it was doing a fractional second
ago but you change your your mind at the
same time and there's a little bit of
computational delay I forgot 100
milliseconds compute or 200 milliseconds
delay humans have probably three four
hundred milliseconds delay that's that's
how you explain this
so anyway uh basically this comes to the
you know
I don't know if you remember anything
here remember what I'm gonna say in the
next these two slides
now this is an intersection there are
four vehicles coming there is no
right-of-way no communication no intent
preference future trajectory info they
don't know what the others are gonna do
they are both running either DF or pcca
u0 comes from the simple trajectory
follower lqr
this bicycle model kinematic
elliptical barrier there are some
constraints on steering acceleration
there's a little bit of radius margin
sampling time 50 milliseconds if you are
interested
um
four vehicles two go straight to turn
left this one is the centralized
follower everything's symmetric
same they are same distance same initial
speed which is at the same time they
have desired speed take a look
huh I don't know why okay you are not
surprised that the gridlock right
that's what we thought it would happen I
I before I I ran I knew what would
happen
um
this one is in more interesting case
it's not as intuitive
low bandwidth the same initial condition
same everything pcca in both cases lower
bending on the left higher bending on
the right
low bandwidth
they pass nicely again we expected this
I knew this would happen
um
really nice right
on the right high bandwidth now these
are all they are more aggressive they're
going to start breaking later
what happens is when you start braking
later you kind of break too late
and then you have to untangle a little
bit
so it's slower
why
well
I have an explanation
the unstable interagent mode is
independent of Lambda you remember that
I said well that doesn't depend on my
parameters if I use smaller Lambda
meaning lower bandwidth I'm going to
start breaking earlier
if I start breaking earlier my
negotiation starts early my exponential
instability kicks in earlier if I start
late right if you come from this is this
is really purely
symmetric case but I think asymmetry is
added because of the solver you know
rounding error or whatever so you go
from really minuscule you need to get
them into
into meters in some time if you have a
little time if you're not going to get
there if you have
twice as much time you may get there
that's basically the explanation
on the DF side so for DF decentralized
foreign policy on the previous slide
bandwid did not play any role that
doesn't matter that one does not have
unstable equilibrium and you don't
observe any any difference
so conclusion
multi-agent system present a complex
control design problem
obviously computational scaling uh
inconsistent info between uh agents
because they don't know what the others
are going to do CBF is an effective way
in my opinion and because convexity and
continuity
and I said likely because I don't think
there is a proof that x-ray is
continuous if we just observe it it
simply case I I said it's continuous but
in general
I don't know if it is continues
uh the two agents it's going to be
continuous while the other ones will not
be even with two agents
uh if you remember anything there are
these blue things here which I
emphasized
instability is our friend it seems
essential if you want negotiation agent
to Asian negotiations
instability is what you need I think
we don't know how to create it
I I don't have any way of creating an
unstable algorithm I could check if you
give them the other I said yeah this is
unstable or no this one is is stable but
I don't know there is no
parameters that would make centralized
control unstable the only way if you
remember the only way I could make it is
make R negative doesn't make sense to
make R negative my radius right so it's
like that's it it's stable because it's
property of the algorithm
and finally the last question is is how
we do it we would slow down well not in
that video I showed you but if these
people actually did slow down the two
guys that Collide if they did slow down
day with extra negotiations they would
give themselves more time
to negotiate the way out of this
avoid the flip-flopping instability
which is a reciprocal dance
that's the end of my talk
I wondered if you would just say a word
about
um you looked at both holonomic and
non-home homonym cases how how important
does that really make a big difference
or in the end not that much uh one thing
that that makes a big difference uh I
have a slide here that says even if the
other one
was
non-cooperating you know just going
through
uh you can still have all delta T kind
of error this is true for holonomic
because you can move sideways
if if it is non-holonomic that that
result does not apply
a bunch of other things that do apply
but not that one and the reason is if
it's coming from the side towards you
uh you are not gonna the natural thing
would be you move out of the way like
this or like this but you cannot move
sideways so you are going to actually
get hit yeah if it is colonomic you can
move sideways because you know that's
just y coordinate you control so you
would move and then I have in another
presentation
I have a nice video and one is chasing
the other
one assume I can show it to you if you
are interested
but one is chasing the other
but the other one does is not aware of
this it is it thinks the other one is
running pcca and they are all
cooperating still
the one with pcca because there is large
disturbance coming right like that the W
is large it actually always accounts and
they actually Chase one another around
and colliding just a little bit
uh
so this as the result says they they
would
uh so but that's true only because the
um
the holonomic agent cannot be broadsided
broadsiding is the problem right you you
have see continuous controller
that's a that's a bad thing about the
continuity that's why I think we humans
have both both switching as well as
continuous part capability but uh if you
if you sit there and you only have a
continuous controller and it's and it
comes straight to you from the side
see if it starts if it's gonna hit you
in the back you're gonna move forward
you're gonna hit in the front you are
going to move backward continuous
control has to have zero somewhere in
between moving forward moving backward
because it's continuous that has to be
zero zero means you're gonna get hit
because you're not going to move your
controller says don't move I mean
because it's continuous yeah
that's why I think as humans we have
both and these guys I unfortunately turn
the switching one
which was unfortunate I'm not saying the
continuous one is solution to all the
problems obviously if you're gonna get
broadsided you won't turn the
this continuous one on
recorded
great I'm having some continuity between
like the last seminar I saw in this one
uh the first I'm seeing of this year so
in the last seminar I saw last year we
were actually talking about traffic
circles in Indiana uh and some of the
impact that that had on improving
traffic Flow by by moving to that one of
the things that they had to do was they
had to give preferenced preferential
right of way to trucks because trucks
might have to occupy a couple of lanes
in order to prevent gridlocking and so
thinking about that and thinking about
your talk I'm curious about sort of you
know both potentially how this would
extend to geometries like a circle
um which is also one of your initial
motivations but also just more broadly
how this might work with asymmetric
actors where you know I have for
instance a lot more size associated with
the truck or I have slightly different
motion constraints how how that might
impact some of these results is there is
there is this sort of symmetry among
actors beyond their actions
um potentially important in these
conclusions
um I don't know which one you want to
look at let's say this one
let's say this one actually
um
you have here uh the minimization for
all and the weights are the same
if you have one of these Js
or even the the ego vehicle could be the
truck I say well it's much more
expensive for me to change uh my my
preferred thing than for other ones you
still enforce the constraint so they are
still going to stop if they can
but the cost inside is going to be much
more expensive if I do something and if
that other ones if they all agree
that the truck should be
baited by Factor iron let's say 10 or 5
or whatever the appropriate number is
then then everything is going to work
for yourself
even if not even if you disagree on the
weights this thing at least in the in
this holonomic case is going to be okay
because it adjusts to whatever the other
ones are doing if basically even if you
put five agents in one of these five
is is not an agent
you're just plowing through right
they're still going to have all of delta
T uh uh violation because the other ones
will realize that
uh that something's wrong and they would
move out of the way and and I have
simulations that show that as I said one
was chasing the other and they would
move again
non-holonomic you you have you lose a
degree of Freedom if you want
you know things that that comes through
very clearly
thanks everyone
[Applause]